hi i'm martin nomander and today i'll
tell you about a pain point for my
previous developer jobs
and how to solve it with modern
technology i wish i had this technology
back then
before my current job as a developer
advocate at google i worked at a string
of startups as a software engineer
i always struggled with how to store
passwords
api keys certificates and other
sensitive data
if i hard coded these secrets into the
source code
i had two problems one anyone with
access to the source repo could see the
secrets
they could copy the secret somewhere
else and we didn't have auditing and
access controls
and two it would be hard to move code
between dev test and production
environments secrets typically differ
between
environments so in my previous job
i did what the 12-factor app methodology
recommends
i put the secrets in environment
variables
that way they were not part of the code
base but the secrets had to be stored
somewhere so i put them in a file which
i had to be careful
not to check into source control at one
job we burned secrets
to a cd that we kept in the cio's desk
drawer
handling files without source control is
awkward
i remember thinking that there must be a
better way of doing it
secret manager in google cloud platform
provides that better way
it has been generally available since
march 2020.
we recently added native integration
with cloud run
which makes it easy to mount secrets in
cloud run services
let's see how we can update an existing
cloud run service to use
secret manager the service is a simple
api
that returns information about different
dog breeds
like this the code reads database user
password etc from environment variables
when it creates the database connection
pool here
the environment variables are shown here
in the cloud console
in plain text
so let's say we want to have better
control and auditing of the database
password by moving it into secret
manager
we see here that the cloudron service
runs as
dog breed api a custom service account
i used the principle of least privilege
when i created this account
so it only has the cloud sql client
role this means that it can connect to
cloud sql databases
but nothing else we will need to
remember this account for the next
step next i will go to the secret
manager in my project
create a new secret for the database
password and
enter its value here now let's see who
can access this password
the dog breed api is not in the list yet
let's add it again we're applying the
principle
of least privilege the dog breed api
account
currently has access to db password but
not any of the other secrets that we see
here this reduces risk
now i'm ready to go back to the cloud
run service
first i remove the dbpass plaintext
environment variable
i feel better already then i'll add it
back
but instead of entering the actual
password
i will point db pass to the password in
secret manager
then i'll click deploy here so this
change takes effect
and look the api still works
so what did we achieve here
well first we can now use the principle
of least privilege for the password and
other secrets
we can define granular permissions for
who can access which
secrets and who can add new secrets
for example we just configured it so our
cloudround service can access
but not write db password in production
and if only a few people in our dev team
are allowed to handle secrets in
production
we reduce the risk of downtime due to
silly mistakes
i know i once mistakenly deleted the
production database at a previous job
second we now have auditing of this
password
by default whenever it is created or
updated
we'll get a log entry like this i
usually also turn on additional logging
so there'll be an entry for whenever a
secret is accessed
as well and we achieved all this
without changing a single line of source
code
delightful but what if our existing code
reads secrets from a file instead of
environment variables
no problem we can configure cloudrun so
that secrets
look like files to the source code
pretty neat
i should also mention there is a third
way of accessing secrets from source
code
our code could make a call to the secret
manager client library
every time it needs a secret this
obviously means that we have to update
our source code
but every time we call the client
library we will get the current value of
the secret
so this method is useful if we expect
secrets to
change often and we don't want to
redeploy our cloud run service every
time that happens
the same is true when we read secrets as
a file
if we access secrets as environment
variables and we update a secret
we need to redeploy the cloud round
service to get the latest value of that
secret this has been an introduction to
using cloud run with secret manager
the docs have a lot more information
like best practices for how to manage
permissions
how to rotate your secrets to reduce
risk and how to aversion
secrets also in the description below
you will find a link to the source code
i used
i really hope that this makes it easier
for you to build secure systems
as developers our code may be entrusted
with some very sensitive data
we carry a big responsibility let's live
up to it
please let me know if this video was
helpful or if you have any questions
also if you have suggestions for new
episodes please add them in the comments
below
until next time
you